hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to folks
why is it movies based on video games
always seen the suck monkey tits let me
think about it
tree fighter Mortal Kombat Super Mario
Brothers even films like The Wizard that
just talked about video games always
seem to suck for whatever reason they're
certainly not getting any better don't
believe me then check out the festering
elephant puke the Hollywood seems to an
entitled double drank a movie so bad
that I can't even come up with a clever
analogy to properly describe how bad it
is well I'll try it's a motion smacking
whore you disgusting piece of retro as
I've ever seen in my entire life no that
doesn't seem to sum up how bad it is but
hell anyone can talk about it it's quite
a different thing to actually experience
it so let's take a gander first of all a
little history Double Dragon was an
arcade game of the 80,000 simple side
scroller freedom of adventure nothing
too complicated just beating the shit
out of any annoying Punk who crossed
your path
god bless senseless violence the game
was so popular that they also made a
Nintendo version which is one of the
highest-grossing games for the NES when
the game so popular Hollywood producers
quickly put their minds together and
came up with the idea to make a movie
about it
seven years later any come on by this
time you could get double dragon and toy
dispensers it's not like this was at the
height of its popularity but oh well
maybe the idea for the movie was just so
good that it could cross the boundaries
of the zeitgeist and give us one hell of
a timeless classic huh grateful to eat
it so the film starts off with this
bullshit thousands of years ago an evil
army of shadow warriors terrorized a
great city of chang-sun the good king
sacrificed himself to create a mystical
medallion the King split it in half this
is the legend of the Double Dragon no
this is the plot to surf ninjas I love
how they identify the location
just by saying somewhere in China like
no one actually wanted to do research
about where the shittiest movie took
place where is this all happening of
somewhere in China so we see a bunch of
ninjas beating the crap out of a bunch
of Chinese monks as one of them hides in
a cave where they worship the yogurt
statue from Spaceballs it turns out the
monk was going for the double dragon
medallion but it's taken away from him
by the sadistic sinister slimy hottest
ninja I've ever seen in my life she
takes in the Delian back to Rama Patrick
who placed the vanilla ice 1000 it turns
out he is the evil ruler of new Angeles
which takes place in the futuristic
world of 2007 oh yeah I remember that
year when global warming flooded the
entire earth nuclear missiles destroyed
all the major cities and then within one
year's time we cleaned it all up funny
couple of months I wrote a lot in my
calendar those days I can tell ya so it
turns out the new Angeles is a crime
ridden hellhole work earthquakes occur
every couple of seconds criminals will
the streets and the police never come
out after dark how's the name different
from the old Angeles in the city we meet
the Leigh brothers Jimmy and Bill they
need every Wednesday at the Karate Kid
reenactment guild where they practice
their infamous karate who's like the
fire blazing dropkick the fearsome
raging roundhouse and the fatal demon
head nookie of doom it's a terrifying
world where criminals wave their fingers
at you little people do whatever the
hell this is and news programs are
hosted by George Hamilton and Vanna
White
wait what I always get them mixed up
whether to go forward or backward great
banner did you just randomly flip
through look at land repairs on
celebrity's name I mean what the hell
George hamil in a Vanna White why
there's the point they have no
connection whatsoever I mean what's next
Andy Dick as the leatherman oh oh are
you two are crazy what's this the new
version of six degrees of Kevin Bacon
Donna's in the news she held a press
conference in Old York today where she
said her marriage to Tom Arnold is
finished oh yes don't you just love
those timeless jokes that will never
become dated Madonna and Tom
Oh gasps it's like they're sensitive
writing skills can see into the future
so after that bit of Nantes Ecuador
Theatre we watch is Jimmy and Billy pick
up the random Asian friend Satori they
get pulled over by an evil gang known as
the Mohawks by the way to all those
morons who are trying to bring this look
back just remember this could be you
bill does a quick file check on the
gangs leader Moby Dick over there is Bo
iboga oh oh sorry but um what was up
with that mug shot is that just the new
format making all criminals honk like a
goose I mean what's the point
imagine I had a mug shot like that we're
on the hunt for a big shot in the
Gambino crime family with even John
Gotti clear then a 1,000 that's a
special returns for the blow Hawks chase
our heroes down all throughout the
streets of new Angeles look at this car
not one thing about it is original it's
got the fire engine from the Bama beale
the computer from Knight Rider the
design of a Ghostbusters car and it even
runs up mr. fusion from Back to the
Future why don't you throw in the Hal
9000 wire act they can't go any faster
I'm sorry Dave but you're completely out
Oh
hahaha I'll just compile in a random
violence these guys will laugh at
anything
hi next week I'm getting our root canal
haha hey I just found out I have cancer
oh I think my favorite scene is when the
heroes use a map to black out the
mohawks vision so what do they do they
use a teletrac or camera to send a
virtual reality simulation into their
car so they can use an alternative way
of steering that's a really clever idea
guys really top-notch but did you ever
consider the possibility of maybe just
simply removing the map with your
fucking hand I mean what there's no
windshield technology in the future
anymore
I mean it'd be easier just to build a
robotic arm to come out and remove the
map for you but what do you expect when
you're using this high-tech 2007
technology so are humans get stuck in a
dead-end where it looks like the Mohawks
have the advantage but another gang
called the Power Core protects them as
their gang leader who I think is giving
great school to be in this movie tell us
the Mohawks to piss off no one
interrupts our Street rendition of
Godspell so our heroes returned to their
home in an old abandoned theater where
Satori tells the two boys about the
medallion she keeps around her neck that
apparently the boy's father gave to her
your father was in the excavation when
it collapsed he gave this to me and
chunks off with a warning
we said the mystical powers of the
dragon are far too dangerous for one
person to possess wasn't the original
plot Double Dragon someone punches a
chick in the stomach and two guys have
to go rescue her what was that story
just too complex for the writers to
figure out meanwhile we see that the
mohawks leader bola Bobo yes that is its
real name is working for the vanilla ice
1000 who wishes to get the other half of
the Double Dragon medallion he's joined
by two Mexican bellhops and dominatrix
Barbie who help him in his evil plan by
visiting the lead Brothers Hall oh good
punch her in the stomach and take her
away Lia we're trying to get this movie
off the ground no one has called me guys
in many years but like a phoenix rising
from the ashes you're incredibly flaming
I have ascended is that code for coming
out the closet so they all have a nice
big chase in the abandoned theater where
they perform some incredible stunt
scenes that Indiana Jones wishes he
could imitate
I always love how small round objects
always seem to have mystical ass-kicking
powers of these movies when they just
walk over them but a headcase what a
heck oh come on there's about a million
other bad puns you can throw in this
fight see it's curtains for you may I
sweep you off your feet
balls in your court it's time to get
pity God even though bad dialogue is bad
I know logically that means that should
be good but it's not it's still bad in
the middle of this fight scene the ice
1000 explains his evil plan forgetting
that when you turn your back it gives
the enemy and all time to hurt you wait
a minute II just jump in the same
hitting twice huh okay I guess part of
the Double Dragon special powers are
restoration things heat up when the
gangly door a Bobo gets an upgrade as
transformed into fat bastard's retarded
pimple covered cousin get in my belly
this giant powerful unstoppable monster
is defeated by a punching bag okay but
the ice 1000 has used his mystical
powers to trap Satori and burn down the
theater guy get the third grade on she
told him a guy Purdue in this situation
well if you would use the curtain in the
back to tie together a couple of
sandbags and with level out the weight
on the other side but or he would just
get the door that so seriously they
showed off their fight moves they showed
vanilla ice cream turned to ash a puppet
but when is the story gonna begin when
are they gonna kidnap the woman and take
her away like in the game I'm sick of
your stalling movie it's time that you
do something with that woman do
something with that walk
well that was harsh
alas poor Satori I hardly knew her
seriously I have no idea who she was
when she their sister their mother their
friend
what well she's just a smear bash on the
sidewalk now as the two brothers tried
to continue on protecting the medallion
without her Jimmy Satori's gone get over
it
the tour is gone and there's nothing we
can do to bring her back but she said I
told us about the dragging a long time
ago she dunked the whole thing on us as
usual well he didn't write her eulogy
unfortunately they come across another
gang who of course wanna beat the crap
they had to fight evil nasties like a
rabble is mine
no yodeling boy and later homes and rich
kings I'm Rick James behalf and of
course the sinister postman randomly
leaps off the tall buildings for no
reason maybe this wasn't such a hot idea
the music just belch got a low musical
score can't keep its lunch down watching
this is it me or are all these games
trying to look like Halloween costume
rejects I keep expecting to see Mickey
Mouse in it
oh go for the jugular next to get on a
speedboat race across the river yeah
remember that from the game how about
the Hollywood tour boat that blocks
their way remember that from the game
and to you'll see a shitty movie so the
boat blows up of course not leaving a
scratch on them and they try to figure
out whether or not they should go to the
Power Core game to ask for help
we need help I'm not asking Mary for
help fine then I'll ask her good then
ask her I'm gonna Esther I'm better oh
wait you just proposed to him already
meanwhile two Mexican bellhop after
filming a double mint gum commercial
revealed that they lost location of the
bleep brothers but ice takes it well I
just want total domination of one major
American city all right of course I'll
never get sick of that joke so the Lee
brothers find the location of a Power
Core only to find out is there quite as
menacing as they thought it would be
welcome to chuck-e-cheese asshole kids
it turns out that our core is just kids
but on the bright side they did manage
to capture the villains assistant of
Bobo subjecting him to the horrible
torture of feeding him spinach my
special affinity guy this is like
waterboarding by pop I mean we're gonna
have to give up some of the personal
freedoms I couldn't get a good good but
the ice 1,000 breaks into Willy Wonka's
torture Asylum and tries to get back his
half of the medallion this should be
suspenseful but I can't tell which gang
members are supposed to be wish he's
more on such as one Indian short of the
Village People there's one scene where
power cords leader is confronted by
dominatrix Barbie oh boy this is gonna
be hot damn it man you ruined my hot
girl-on-girl action I guess we do get a
scene when she ties you to a pole with
her own window
I'd like to generally I could people
have yes yes now coloring with cream and
maple syrup then dress her up in a
sailor's uniform place her with some
clown makeup makeup prance around
singing on the good ship lollipop it
that while I have issues but the ice
1000 comes in and possesses Bill's
brother Jimmy he raises his hand which
somehow silences the chaotic mob and
challenges Billy to either hand over the
medallion or watch his brother die so
Billy backs him off into a corner where
he threatens to wait a minute the Double
Dragon arcade game is right behind him
that makes no fans how do you make a
double dragon are taking movies based on
the Double Dragon are changing and your
cake game is in the background has
everybody lost their minds
it's like saying Frodo and jr. are
talking Lord of the Rings movies reading
the book jr. are Tolkien's Lord of the
Rings it makes no sense the movies
universe should have just imploded
but just moseying along sings our
dialogue until
you
so it turns out they destroy the game no
doubt an obvious metaphor and managed to
get the villain out of Jimmy's body
thanks bro you gave me back my dignity
to do Iron Chef America but the villain
looking nothing like the t1000 here now
has both hands of the medallion given
him the incredible ability to turn into
these two guys that's a pretty lame
medallion but of course the heroes get
the medallion back by doing a ballerina
spin and put it together to become
powerful themselves then I see the
Wonder Twins do this once
and so they transform themselves into
the fearsome duo of seam free then Roy
destiny has brought together the double
dragons
garbin as I guarded you oh hey thanks
motherly sister ish acquaintance so they
defeat the bill and he gets dragged off
to jail and he makes his big sinister
revenger speech at the end they got bad
what do you meet my lawyers
I claim that kid is going places bottom
line this movie is horn it's about as
entertaining as colon cancer no one in
the right mind should would are good
like this movie maybe this is the time
that filmmakers will wake up and realize
that they have to work hard in order to
make movies about videogames interesting
you can't just make crap and expect it
to be good in fact I think now is the
time that filmmakers may stop worrying
about money and simply concentrate on
making decent entertaining films about
videogames may God strike me down if I'm
wrong it's a mirror have I been dying a
lot recently
Oh